foreign
well to illustrate just how much
feminism has affected science and
actually changed in some ways how
science is done I'll give you one
example so
um in Charles Darwin wrote in his
private correspondence and in his uh
books his public papers that women there
we go there's a patriarchy again that
women were intellectually inferior to
men that's where the title of my book
came from that we really are less smart
less creative that we're capable of
doing Less in pretty much every field
and the way he came to this conclusion
was
by looking at women in Victorian society
around him and seeing that they weren't
attaining attaining as the word that he
used as much as men were so he didn't
see women in powerful positions he
didn't see as many women scientists or
artists he didn't really consider that
women at that time didn't have the vote
they didn't have access to higher
education they were barred from the
scientific academies very often a girl
didn't have the same level of primary
education as a boy did so just how they
were supposed to be attaining as much as
men that is a question you didn't
consider which is surprising given how
careful a scientist he was in every
other respect when it came to women he
kind of had this very blanket View and
that was true of many Victorian male
biologists
Francis Galton his cousin Drew up a
beauty map of Britain where he went
around with a secret kind of device in
his trousers where he would see women in
areas and decide is she good looking or
not and then he drew Duty map of Britain
based on it but even you know more
worrying than that Walter Heap who was a
reproductive biologist in the early 20th
century he wrote an entire book just a
few years before women or some women got
the vote in 1918 arguing that women were
wasting their reproductive energy by
going out and campaigning
an entire book on this one subject and
it ended on a very threatening note
saying that if you continue in this
fashion then men will have to kind of
rise up and
I mean he leaves it open-ended but it
you know there was a Veiled Threat at
the end that we will do something about
it so this wasn't kind of a scientist
just being scientists and putting
information out there
you know and not really thinking about
the political consequences as well as
people like Darwin who were saying these
things there were also other scientists
who very who are very conscious of the
political consequences of they of what
they were saying and said it anyway
because it suited their politics
now one of the cornerstones of all these
ideas about female behavior and female
intellectual capability rested on sexual
differences between men and women so
this idea that men were promiscuous and
um that they wanted to spread their seed
and that because of this they had out
evolved women because they
um they had to be impressive you know to
attract as many females as possible
whereas women were kind of sexually
chased because they just wanted the one
best possible
father for their one child and that they
were passive as a result that they
didn't need to be so impressive you know
this peacock and P hen difference and he
extended that to humans that we are as
different as Peak almost as different as
peacocks are to pee hence
now this carried on for decades and
decades in the 1970s there were
biologists like Robert trivers an
incredibly important evolutionary
biologist one of the most important John
Simons who wrote the book on human
sexual behavior who continued with this
pattern of thought women are sexually
very different from Men
alongside them there were for the first
time unlike In Darwin's time women
working as biologists in the field
primatologists you know of across the
board you you were seeing women become
professors and one of them was Sarah
blafferhardy who was an evolutionary
biologist who worked alongside Don
Simons and Robert trivers and she had
grown up in a very patriarchal Texan oil
family she had to run away from home to
marry the man that she wanted to marry
and she looked at all this research of
her colleagues and thought actually this
doesn't chime with my experience I don't
see women being as modest as they claim
that we're being how is it that they're
writing these things
and she made this wonderful observation
now look at um look at FGM here is a
practice that has been around for
millennia
it's incredibly brutal female genital
mutilation millions of women around the
world have had this done to them who are
alive today
we're essentially a young girl has is
cut open and then sewed up it's
incredibly painful for her to have sex
so it essentially puts her off sex until
she gets married often when they get
married they have to be cut open in
order to be able to have sex with their
husband and then cut open again in order
to be able to give birth
now FGM is just one very extreme example
of
sexual repression female sexual
repression but we have many more we've
had them throughout history arguably
religions are built around this idea of
controlling women's sexuality
um we have you know chastity belts we
have moral double standards we have
every elaborate violent and non-violent
means possible all over the world of
controlling female sexual behavior and
they have been around for millennia
Sarah's point was if women are so modest
and chased then why do we do this
victorians when they looked at the women
around them of course they seem modest
to you because for two thousand or three
thousand years you've been controlling
deliberately repressing their sexuality
her as a feminist her feminist ideas
affected the science that she did and
how she thought about that problem and
it made a difference and it made science
better as a result
like so much
[Applause]
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to The Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV